nick foles taking over as a starting
quarterback for the chicago bears after
leading the bears from a 16 point
deficit against the falcons based on a
gut feeling from coach matt nagy who
would have dreamed
that if mitchell trubisky was benched
for nick foles the bears would also be
3-0 but that's the record they take
into this game against the very good
indianapolis colts at two and one
fill in the blank time peter with nick
foles starting the bears are
what
respectable and
a more a team more suited to make the
playoffs
than with mitchell trubisky and
the one point i would make about foals
mike is
that we can say whatever we want about
well you know he's never done it for a
full season
and boy look what has happened when he
was in this situation
you know what he's a pretty damn good
savior
and i don't say that lightly i mean it i
mean it because he did it twice
in philadelphia and he's handed the job
in jacksonville
and he doesn't do it and then he gets
hurt okay and now he comes in and plays
one of the best quarters of his life uh
to win a game that they had no business
winning in atlanta
so to me he gives the chicago bears
the best chance now to be that seventh
seed
yeah i agree with you completely peter
and
my concern is that we've seen him in the
past
we've seen him take big hits his first
game
as the starting quarterback for the
jacksonville jaguars he exited with a
broken collarbone after taking a big hit
on a touchdown pass he took a big hit on
a touchdown pass
on sunday you know one of the reasons i
think that matt nagy has been
extra respectful of mitchell trubisky
didn't name nick foles the starter right
after the game
waited until monday morning to make it
clear that that's the direction they
were going
i think maggie knows there's a chance
he's going to need trubisky
that no even if falls is the guy
there's a chance he's not going to be
able to go and they're going to need
trubisky back in the field and he may
have to
he may have to do what he did in week
one which is bring the team back from a
17-point deficit to win the game
look here's the bottom line to chicago
bears situation
matt nagy needs to go into every sunday
saying what do i do this week to win
this game he's not trying to build a
boeing 747
you know he is trying to to tinker and
figure out how am i
beating the indianapolis colts how are
we gaining yards
on matt eberflus and darius leonard this
week
and those are his big issues and
i think he's been good at it so far and
look
we also know mike that based on the body
language
and the face that we've seen of mitchell
trubisky on the sidelines you saw when
they played the rams last year
you know that that this guy wears his
emotions
on his face and you know clearly
you don't want to lose mitchell trubisky
when you know
there's a decent chance you're gonna
need him at some point the rest of this
year
and that's what makes what's happened so
stunning i talked to him after the week
two win over the giants and he sounded
so different than he ever had before
there was a confidence there
there was an assuredness there that
hadn't been there and he's 2-0 he's
riding high
but there has to be a hell of a story as
to why matt and aggie decided in that
moment
in that game to make the switch and
maybe
he just between looking at the film
watching practice seeing what foals was
doing
whatever caused him to go with trubisky
week one flipped
pretty quickly and they're three i never
would have dreamed this team would be
undefeated at the time the switch was
made
from trubisky to foals i thought it was
coming at some point
i said dave at some point foals are
going to play this year
and uh who would have dreamed that it
would be under these circumstances one
interesting fact about this game
the colts led by frank reich
who was the offensive coordinator of
that eagles team where nick foles came
in and
after carson wentz was injured led them
to the super bowl won the super bowl
wright got the job
reich knows falls knows what makes him
tick peter i don't know how much of that
makes its way to matt eberflus and makes
its way into the game plan and makes its
way into how they defend nick foles
but if any coach out there knows nick
foles it's frank reich
well there's no there's no doubt about
it and i'll never forget mike one of my
favorite stories that i've done in
recent years is
going to sit with uh doug peterson
frank reich and um uh
uh john d philippe what's this no
i thought it was john d felipe no in
philadelphia
but but anyway it might grow the who was
the quarterback coach at the time
reich was the offensive coordinator and
what happened
uh they deconstructed the you know how
they
ended up beating uh the new england
patriots
in the super bowl six days afterwards
and the reverence that frank reich had
in that
two-hour session with me and those
coaches
the reverence he had for nick foles
you know was just it was so
it's something that i just remember it
in his voice every time man falls
falls and so there is great admiration
and respect and there's also an
acknowledgement
that nick foles can go on one of these
runs again
and and mike he's got better receivers
now
in chicago than he had then in
philadelphia
and speaking of philadelphia you know
one of the ramifications of nick foles
return to a starting job it just adds
even more pressure
on the eagles and i feel like as they've
continued to go all in with carson wentz
between
trading up to making the second overall
pick picking him over nick foles after
folz led those two great playoff runs
that caused some to say maybe falls is
their long-term guy
giving wence the big contract i feel so
much pressure and urgency on
these eagles and let's focus on that
sunday night game on nbc the eagles at
the 49ers
carson wentz needs to be what peter for
philly to pull off the upset of the
49ers
he needs to take what is right in front
of him
he needs to stop thinking i gotta make
big plays he needs to start thinking
i need to make plays period and
i think if you watched him every time he
throws the ball
down field you said oh my god you get
nervous
you get nervous whereas the carson wentz
of the first
you know three months of 2017
he said oh my god this guy's the next
superstar of football
and so i think he needs to stop
trying to do too much even if it means
that he's throwing only wheel routes
and intermediate stuff to zachary's
that's
that's what i think he needs to
concentrate on yeah i agree with you i
feel like he's trying to score 20 points
on every play that he feels like one
game is going to push back all of the
doubters
the fans in philadelphia aren't happy
you know it
it's sims and i talked about this this
week it's almost as if winning a super
bowl has made those fans crazier
that they they're they want it every
year now
it's like a drug instead of just being
happy that they finally have one
that they're less patient with the team
than they ever were before because
that's the standard that every edition
of the eagles is going to be compared to
until the memory of that super bowl
fully fades all right brown's in the
cowboys
a browns cowboy shootout if it happens
if it happens a shootout favors who
dallas because i just trust
uh you know i trust dak prescott
a lot more than i trust baker mayfield
and
i say that in part because of the
weaponry
but in part because i just think that at
some point even though dak prescott
failed at the end of the seattle game
you know
i think there's going to be a lot of
emotion on baker mayfield in this game
first of all
it's almost a home game for him he lives
in austin
he's a texas guy southwest conference
this is a
big big deal for him to be playing the
dallas cowboys
in arlington texas okay so there's going
to be a lot
it's going to be a you know a mega game
in his mind
and i think the other part of this is
you know
i had a conversation with dak prescott a
couple of weeks ago
and the thing i the thing that really
stuck with me about that is
and it sounds weird but the reverence he
had for cd lamb
and and just what cd lamb brings to this
offense is basically when you play
cleveland
you got to worry about miles garrett
okay but if you have a lot of weapons
and you can neutralize miles garrett you
should be able to find
those weapons and so that's why i just
believe right now this week
in uh in in uh the cowboys a little bit
more
but can i just say one other thing mike
and i don't mean to monopolize this but
in my opinion right now when you look at
the cowboys
aldon smith has been a huge star you
made the point the other day
you know it's amazing how he doesn't win
you know
defensive player of the month in the nfc
he's leading him in sacks
what an incredible story hasn't played
in five years it's unbelievable
here is the bigger thing about the
dallas cowboys and why
we're all saying hey the brown's got a
chance
because demarcus lawrence and everson
griffin
in 238 snaps
combined between them in three games
have one sack
and two significant quarterback
pressures that is not good enough
you're basically telling alden smith hey
listen you gotta do it all
so to me i really think the cowboys have
got to get
better production from their big stars
on the defensive front
and i'm glad you mentioned that peter
because one of the things that sims and
i have identified is a line of
demarcation between the good
quarterbacks and the great quarterbacks
the good quarterbacks can run the play
that's called but when it all falls
apart
they can't get it done they can't
improvise they can't come up with a
second unscripted play to save the play
that failed
the great quarterbacks have the mobility
and the ability to keep the play alive
and make a good decision and get the
ball down the field
and i put baker mayfield and gardner
minshew
kind of right on that border line where
against some teams
they can outrun the pass rush and they
can maneuver
and they can improvise if they need to
against other teams
they can't and it's just a question of
how good is that pass rush
and that's the challenge for the cowboys
and you hit the nail on the head alton
smith is unstoppable even when you
double team him
he fights through it it's incredible to
see what he's doing
if he could just get some help from the
other guys in that front seven
then you make baker mayfield into guy
who can't
pivot away from the play that's called
and extend the play with his legs
because he's getting swallowed up by the
pass rush
look the other thing that you have to
admire about aldon smith
is that he knew that all eyes were going
to be on him
and that he was going to have to perform
and perform early
or everybody would be saying what a
wasted thing by the cowboys you can't
take a guy
who hasn't played football in five years
and say
hey play a feature role in our defense
so there was a lot of pressure on aldon
smith early
and he has totally responded so far mike
the best game that
any defensive player has played in the
nfl in the first quarter of the season
alden smith at seattle in week three
yeah that's the thing shaq barrett's the
defensive player of the week for chasing
around a bunch of backup quarterbacks in
denver
alton smith sacked russell wilson three
times
he sacked russell wilson three times and
uh it's a shame he's not getting the
recognition but we're doing what we can
because it's a great story he was
homeless a year ago homeless
a year ago fighting through addiction
problems and so far winning and
it just it's sad peter to think of what
he could have been
if he would have been playing
continuously
from 2013 or so when his problems really
escalated until now all right saints at
lions through three weeks the saints
offense has been what peter
unsurprising and you're saying what do
you mean unsurprising
and what i will say is that any team
that for 70 percent
of of of a period of time who doesn't
have
the most explosive weapon on offense
and you're and this is a guy who drew
brees has grown to lean on
every time he goes back to pass if you
don't have michael thomas
i mean how good are you going to be so
i'm not
really shocked and you know mike i know
everybody is making
a huge deal oh my god breeze he's
falling you know he's
he he's not going to be able to rebound
all i'd ask you to do is
just and again stats can lie i get that
but if you look at his statistics yards
per attempt
completion percentage things like that
the important things
uh to me he's not
horrible compared to the last three or
four years and the reason why he's not
having the success thrown down field
in my opinion traequan smith is not
michael thomas
and so i want to give him a fair
chance with his compliment of players
to still be a great player and without
having michael thomas in there i think
it's a little bit unfair to
be digging a hole for the guy amazing to
say it's a desperation game for the
saints
this weekend but it is they need this
one after losing two in a row even more
desperation in houston
winless vikings winless texans the loser
of this game
is what peter
all but eliminated from the playoff hunt
you don't go all in four what is it one
team
has gone 0 and 4 and made the playoffs
92 chargers
92 chargers bobby ross's first year
there
yeah and and look it would be one thing
if i could look at either of these teams
and say they could go on a seven-game
winning streak
i i mean look kirk cousins can get hot
but can kirk cousins win
seven in a row uh you know with this
team right now the way it is i don't see
it
can desean watson overcome the problems
he has
on his offensive line and can their
defense
be dominant again in houston i don't see
it
neither of these teams can recover from
owen four
and even at 0-3 it's a long shot here
are the odds to win the division from
points bet
sports book the new official sports
betting partner of nbc sports houston
plus 750 even at 0-3 in a division
where well the titans are 3-0 but it
feels like they're living on borrowed
time they've beaten three teams that
just aren't very good
grand scheme of things by a total of six
points minnesota at plus 900 there are
the giants
at plus 2200 i'm surprised by that for
the giants because they're in the worst
division
and oh and three they're only a game out
of first place peter
i'm not ready that just seems like long
long that's a slap in the face for the
new york football
giants because i think the reason is in
the nfc east
you want to know why those odds are so
long because daniel jones
who spent all off season whatever it is
that he did and i don't know what he did
trying to make sure that he doesn't have
the turnover bug again
six turnovers in three games what has
changed
not much that's why the new york giants
who
and i keep saying this they're gonna win
a few games i don't know three four
five i don't know they're not awful the
new york jets are awful
the giants are not awful there's a hole
between 31 and 32 in this league
a gap right best team in new york
put put put the put the signs on the
subways
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports